ma pulse ora tutti a io misti racchiusi
la mattina abbiamo registrato un video
di al garrobo insomma con giampiero che
ovviamente ho perso quindi devo rifarlo
lo rifaccio però non c'è più jean lo
faccio da solo
jean è contento avevamo fatto abbastanza
schifo quindi oggi da solo in due
facciamo schifo quindi da solo proverò a
battere il mio record che di 31 risposte
azzeccati di fila quindi l'ex co ragazzi
prima vedere se del tuo battere il mio
record
partiamo con van den xvi che cercato
mezza volta e brasile brasile avrà
giusto quei tre milioni e mezzo
4 milioni solo per uno sguardo del tizio
pay day long sopra zero non è delicato
sia quindi brasil e forse è meglio che
mi documenti però sono uguali quindi a
posto the wolf of wall street al almeno
un milione e mezzo non lo facciamo è da
tutti ed è allora qualsiasi di spostato
va bene quindi ma tanto è uguale marca
vacca magari pensavo punto di più
comunque ha ragione rainforest quindi
non l'ho data a caso in realtà
vabbè partenza da cani le trovo american
idol o tesco tesco avrà quei 16 milioni
e mezzo
oggettivamente i sei soldi meno di meno
attenzione taylor swift di più del di
sex worker rete lo fissiamo sul milione
e mezzo due più o meno è la madonna e
l'amateur quanta gente che cerca taylor
swift è avanti ragazzi queste quella
buona è che scorre 3 attenzione ciò
frazer meno prescindere madonna che
basette già sto tizio che un fratello al
costo del vasetto web comic book di meno
io metterei professiamo di più meno male
avrei sbagliato
ok nascita o mio dio nemmeno meno che
fortuna wenders wei wei sanderson almeno
almeno un milione c'è la mamma mia o
ignorante la gente però egitto di più
egitto di più two million e l'egitto va
beh per forza non so neanche cosa voglia
dire sinestesia meno mamma mia
forse dovrei documentarmi va bene va
bene questa cosa buona e ragazze ma 10
kamoun devi fare quello che appena fatto
tre volte meno
black porca vacca però si chiama vanta
blacks nicki minaj più diventa black
insomma ok doni d'arco madonna
quantomeno questo film ragazzo non avete
mai visto con l'arco e con un guardate
lo so non dormite madonna però quanto è
cercato bugs bunny di più incredibile
c'è c'è il paragone mi hanno fatto senza
volerlo donnie darko e bugs bunny sempre
di conigli si parla
diciamo che un po il genere non è lo
stesso questa scena è epocale di haier
lo d'armi l'arco e bugs bunny va bene
box da anni ma veramente se facciamo un
sondaggio tutti quanti conoscete donnie
darko
ma non bugs bunny c'è la maggior parte
di voi conosce doni da chi non conosce
bugs bunny corinthians gareth bale
porca vacca quanto ci ho azzeccato
bravissimo vorrei già i complimenti sei
un maestro di questo già come ho fatto a
fare trentuno angelo riding che non mi
piace perché diventi una specie di
preservativo athletics athletics
gambling meno
so anche cosa voglia dire né meno ok
nonesa ricky si ampli git fisher creato
di più tra triathlon e blueberry wine
triathlon newberry wine che globale dove
però sarei curioso di assaggiarlo per
andrè in coma etilico uguale la guerra
del bet del vietnam già più di sicuro
del blu barry white sono 67.000 però
invece molto e bene a tutti la studiano
giustamente quando c'è giusto il
lanciarazzi sulla spalla fa niente io vi
giuro che sto gioco qua mette in con per
due cose randomiche è incredibile che ci
sia piuttosto matching tra le varie cose
comunque bordo world workshop per forza
c'è qualcosa che comunque non va e
secondo me perché non è possibile molto
più conosciuta seconda guerra mondiale
che la guerra è una prova tra l'altro
guardate c'è hitler tutto serio quello
lì tutto preoccupato che per vedere se
lo sta guardando e poi c'è quello dietro
che hai dong i [ __ ] che proprio
complimenti plaster credo che sia
un supereroe facciamo meno porca vacca i
blaster quando sono in quanto sono
cercati al giorno d'oggi empire state
building io sono stato qua sopra
e stato bello tiger tiger nel senso che
proprio l'altra empire state building e
ateismo ma adatto questa non è porta
ticinese a milano a caso c'è una cella
photos wider lover divo un ragazzo con
uno scolapasta in testa che sta a milano
importati cinese va bene credo meno meno
male non mi ha fatto perdere portati
cinese di più sud corea di più perfetta
non è che ci sono i bts hanno alzato un
pò allora notturno eni mouse
non ho idea di cosa sia porco del
demonio morto incastrato in corea
io lo sapevo io lo sapevo lo sapevo lo
sapevo perché le cose che non vi devo
andare non devo andare a in base alle
cose che conosco una sensazione perché
se non è un senso comunque ragazzi
vorrei fare notare una roba che il
database aggiornato nelle ricerche del
2017 con cio riker lover del 2020
vescovo john e john sono beauty john e
johnson
ma andate a cagare tutti a manetta
proprio stamani uno spavento al sex
position stanno messo due gummy bear ok
meno questa volta ce la facciamo una
volta me lo sento questo è più più più
lo valvo mib ajvide great atom berg
hancock di più bangkok dai dai è giusy
ferreri 50 canzoni miami dolphin di meno
di bangkok andate a cagare voi e rugby
sto scherzando mi piacerebbe poi non è
con le football americano dei ragazzi
non c'è proprio verso gli hai che aveva
proprio google feud per chi non lo
sapesse google tv di una specie di roma
dove devi completare le sentenze che
google dovrebbe completare da solo se tu
scrivi una parola ad esempio scholl dai
sei ormai dovreste dovrei vendere la mia
macchina è quella l'abbia trovata life
la mia vita ma andate a cagare la mia
casa la mia casa adesso le mie orecchie
sono sporche sono grosse
small chiude gigantesche ma andate a
cagare auto bild a come costruire una
casa house in minecraft se c'è me ne
vado madonna si guarda 8 build sports
night 8 build a trojan horse mac pc sul
web si nota che ai guai cheated on my
boyfriend suite adobe a free and the
sicuro with a girl primo esatto mi
chiamo a decidere noi warfare 2
boh non so ragazzi con suo padre con il
mio con il mio ex co il mio migliore
amico con il suo amico con il mio amico
col mio ex marito come extra di san
bitter bisogno di pronuncia ma più
grosso ha ideato with mark matematica è
sicuro
my lucky number is that is a 17 non è di
nessuno 10 88 ma andate a cagare cento
quindi 7 c'era semplicemente doveva
raggiungere quando si min
ma che ne so io ma perché sono stato
morso da un cane
ok da un serpente spider ragno da una
formica dai da un numero da un avvocato
radioattivo
ok basper cosa vuol dire a jack lloyd
wright di active lawyer alla bit buy
non ho capito questa cosa ma questo vuol
dire aver bit buy a radioactive lawyer
da un avvocato radioattivo io voglio
morire da un da un ragno radioattivo
scritto ragnolo andava bene ma ragno
radioattivo si perché capita molto di
più il ragno radioattivo che ragno certo
perché tutti mi chiamo morsi dai ragni a
chernobyl
mi sembra ovvio ragazzi basta con google
feud io veramente non so quale peggio se
questo l'altro però va bene però mi è
piaciuto signori schede via chiare
specie con la bellissima campane fine
quella di risotto perché con la campagna
vi permette di rimanere aggiornati sui
tuoi video che esco e noi come sempre ci
vediamo allora servito da ragazzi
[Musica]